hi guys hi congratulations on this movie
it's really really an interesting cop
drama but obviously there's the whole
other element to police brutality and
racial justice so what do you want
audiences to get out of this what is the
message of this we can say this enough
that our hope is that people make the
decision to do what's good and and I
know it's not easy to it's not the most
popular thing but if we could get more
people to be like Naomi Harris's
character especially and obviously the
law enforcement that's what we're
dealing with here then then we'd be off
to a good start as a country yeah I
think that's what the hope is right I
mean look and we're going through some
interesting times as a country
you know what rolls down from the top
yeah and the injustice is that we've
seen and you know racial economic all
kinds of injustice is and that it takes
just one person to really be steadfast
and make some change and it's not
popular but it's what's necessary we're
gonna continue and if you wanna call it
whistle boarding that's what she is
right whatever it takes you can get it
done whistle blowers snitch whatever it
takes you know some people are speaking
up about what it takes to make the world
a better place and that's what it's
about it's not about filling your
pockets how much can I get
what can I do to you know to you know
make myself a profit it's like what's
long-term what's long-term it's an easy
to making change like that you know it's
easy to say okay one cops with New
Orleans that where they have no they're
all in trouble because of Katrina still
and it's like I'm gonna come in here and
I'm gonna do the right thing and and
then the work begins right so it's it's
all of that unpopular difficult stuff
that we need to kind of face up to yeah
speaking of that one person that Naomi
in the suit is so commanding on screen
all you guys share scenes were so it was
like seeing her in this one she's
talking about how you don't really see a
lead role for female cops it was like
seeing her in this role I thought she
was really believable like I didn't not
he's believable because she's a great
actress the thing what I liked about the
script and what it did that a lot of
movies don't do it made it authentic in
a way that okay she's not a big you know
stature wise she's
she's still a female sort of you know
she's not a huge person just he's not
beating men up like I'm here to fight
semen Frank but it's a believable thing
where she's vulnerable
but she's resourceful right she's you
know she takes a hit but what can I do
to like try to get out of this like
she's struggling but she she over she
exceeds expectation it'sit's a
believable struggle struggling character
that is at the center of film that
people are cheering for but they don't
necessarily know that she's gonna come
out because you see the frailty there
sometimes you see the vulnerability you
don't see a person that can just walk
through me kick everybody's butt but
somehow she finds a way to win it all
that's what that's what I like about it
it's an app literally plausible thing
when you look at it and the struggling
two journeys there without something we
walk in you go down and by that I bought
it you know now I'm sitting in a room
with Luke Cage Thunder and Brock rumlow
I can't think of a better broom even if
I stay on me because she might jump into
the comment she is yes I talked to her
about it already so what advice would
you give her for jumping in the comic
book world because that fanbase is a
whole other yeah fan base what advice
would you give a try to try to get
licensee for your own image dealing with
the fans
good luck working with Tom Hardy Luke
Cage know you have the hit show with
evil I know there's the Disney streaming
service people wonder when Luke Cage got
canceled maybe there's a whole move that
Marvel is gonna redo it for this extreme
have you heard anything is there any
talk at all people ask me you know
honestly uh it's a contractual thing
that if we my phone rings that I'll know
that their pop is possibly I don't I
don't think about it because you know
that character doesn't belong to me they
could reboot it they could recast it
they can do whatever they want to do
with it they want to call me I'll pick
up the phone but ultimately um you know
I'm just thinking about black and blue
evil and and you'll see what happens you
know awesome congratulations yes
you